happy day after Christmas you guys
so did you get everything you wanted me
neither I'm Jewish we got a big sack of
holiday cheer for you we got a bunch of
bloopers outtakes and b-sides from this
past year what are you gonna watch a
Christmas story again how many times can
you watch that damn movie
watch this some people said that Quentin
Tarantino being a white guy doesn't have
the right to tell that story what do you
think about that for me I think it
depends on how he tells the story
okay maybe Jake hook was a little off
the chain I'm not gonna say it was it
was Unchained oh that's awful I'm
poisoned I can't do anything now
I'm poisoned look at he's alive I mean
good plan Japanese dude but terrible
execution slit his throat mom wouldn't
you have slipped his throat
thank you guys
here look guys let's battle royale was
lady Shannon spells talk to me I have to
abide by the oaths that I took not to
divulge any both new that is he's not
elbow he's not elbow I'm giving it to
you on a silver platter Dylan what's the
best way to kill a witch that's an
offensive question burn her
girl the best way to kill a Jew for a
black person or a Christian I can't I
guess a gun poison
droning so you've gone with the blue
contacts just like just like your friend
Amen you saw him yeah brothers he heard
it here first he Man and Superman
brothers oh yeah you have the same last
name man
how often to tourists hit on you uh
every deal and then I get hit on by
tourists but it's not so often once in a
great while go I do get hit on by a
tourist yeah and every now and then I
took her up on it oh really
oh yeah I've taken girls up to the park
up the street had some fun up there what
do you mean have some fun up there in
other words I've been behind the bush
no way Oh Superman's gonna be gone for
an hour and a half while Lois is
searching for him while doomsday is
running amok destroying the world
showing more 9/11 porn that we can get
because that's what summer movies do my
9/11 form would be george w bush and bin
Laden double teaming and milf as Katie
Holmes get a bad rap just because she
was married to Tom Cruise no she has a
bad rap because she goes huh what but
she did have a great rack in the gift
that's my honorable mention okay you had
a thought Mike about Katie Holmes is rat
yes Katie Holmes rat Mike Carlson go
dynamite which one of these crazy
futuristic rip I feel like I spit there
that was great to watch oh my god
by the way what do you thinks gonna
happen in season four
I couldn't pull up I could not pull up
what a nice time guys 2013 was a blast I
hope you guys enjoyed watching these
shows as much as we enjoyed making what
should we do in 2014 do you want to see
a panel talking about the best chick
flicks of all time you want to see Nick
Mundy wrestle a bear or should we debate
John Travolta's hair versus NIC cages
hair let us know in the comments section
below best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I'll let you have a safe and
happy new year see in 2014 I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter my wife
died um ask each of you gentlemen to
just sit on my lap and tell me your
Christmas wish I don't know if I don't
I've got okay bad sciatica tip number
two your first request shouldn't be for
inappropriate physical contact with
a-list actors